let's say that f of x
is equal to x over the square root of x
squared plus 1. and i want to think
about the limit of f x
the limit
of f x as x approaches positive infinity
and the limit
of f of x
as x approaches negative infinity so
let's think about what these are going
to be
well once again and i'm not doing this
in an ultra rigorous way but more in an
intuitive way is to think about what
this function approximately equals as we
get larger and larger and larger x's
this isn't the case if we're getting
very positive x's very in positive
infinity direction or very negative is
still the absolute value of those x's
that are very very very large as we
approach positive infinity or negative
infinity
well in the numerator we only have one
term we have this x term but in the
denominator we have two terms under the
radical here and as x gets larger and
larger and larger either in the positive
or the negative direction this x squared
term is going to really dominate this
one you can imagine when x is a million
you're going to have a million squared
plus one the value of the denominator is
going to be dictated by this x squared
term so this is going to be
approximately
equal to x
over
the square root
of
x squared this term right over here the
1 isn't going to matter isn't going to
matter so much when we get large very
very very large x's and this right over
here x over the square root of x squared
or x over the principal root of x
squared this is going to be equal to x
over
if i square something and then take the
principal root remember the principal
root is the positive square root of
something then i'm essentially taking
the absolute value of x it's going to be
equal to x over the absolute value of x
for
x approaches infinity or for x
approaches negative infinity so another
way to say this another way to restate
these limits is as we approach infinity
this limit
we can restate it as the limit this is
going to be equal to the limit as x
approaches infinity
of x over the absolute value of x now
for positive x's the absolute value of x
is just going to be x this is going to
be x divided by x so this is just going
to be 1.
similarly right over here we're taking
the limit as we go to negative infinity
this is going to be the limit
of x over the absolute value of x as x
approaches negative infinity remember
the only reason why i was able to make
this statement is that f of x and this
thing right over here become very very
similar or you can kind of say converge
to each other as x approaches as x gets
very very very large or x gets very very
very very negative
now for negative values of x the
absolute value of x is going to be
positive x is obviously going to be
negative and we're just going to get
negative 1. and so using this we can
actually try to graph we can actually
try to graph our function so let's try
to do that so let's say that is my
y-axis
this is
my x-axis
and we see that we have two horizontal
asymptotes we have one horizontal
asymptote at y is equal to 1. so let's
say this right over here is y is equal
to 1. let me draw the
let me draw that line as a dotted line
we're going to approach this thing and
then we have another horizontal
asymptote at y is equal to negative 1.
so that might be right over there y is
equal
y is equal to
negative 1. and if we want to plot at
least one point we could think about
what does f of 0 equal
so f of 0 is going to be equal to 0 over
the square root of 0 plus 1 or 0 squared
plus 1. well that's all just going to be
equal to
0. so we have this point
right over here
and we know that as x approaches
infinity we're approaching this blue
horizontal asymptote so it might look
something like
like this
like let me do it a little bit
differently
let me do a little bit
there you go
clean this up so it might look something
like this
but that's not the color i wanted to use
so it might look something
something
like
like that
we get closer and closer to that
asymptote is as x gets larger and larger
and then
like this we get closer and closer to
this asymptote as x approaches
negative as x approaches negative
infinity i'm not drawing it so well so
that right over there is y is equal to
f of x and you can verify this by taking
a calculator trying to plot more points
or using some type of graphing
calculator or something but anyway i
just wanted to tackle another situation
we're approaching infinity and or
negative infinity and we're trying to
determine the horizontal asymptotes and
remember the key is just to say what
terms dominate as x becomes very
approaches positive infinity or negative
infinity to say well what is that
function going to approach and it's
going to approach this horizontal
asymptote in the positive direction and
this one in the negative